depuis novembre geneviève tousignant
quitte montréal quelques heures par
semaine et se retrouve en tête à tête
avec un cheval je me concentrerai ce que
je fais avec le cheval elle la taille de
l'animal oblige un petit peu seul
l'intervenante sociale doit continuer
d'aider une clientèle défavorisée qui
vit encore plus d'isolement et de
détresse à cause de la pandémie
c'est pas toujours aussi simple de
répondre aux besoins il ya des
puissances examen elle voit le refuge a
acheté secours comme une sorte de chs ld
pour chevaux on veut le brosser on veut
regarder si ses pattes sans forêt chaque
fois que je viens j'apprends quelque
chose c'est sûr c'est quelque chose que
j'appris semoule à 25 ans maximus et
comme un septuagénaire maximus et bien
sorte que ville de montréal il faisait
la calèche avant d'être ici tellement au
mois de janvier
je sais après que sa terre était au
centre ville les tricheurs retraite chez
nous ça donne un deuxième chance aux
chevaux qui vient chez nous de venir ici
puis ça donne une deuxième chance aux
humains
le refuge qui accueille des groupes de
personnes autistes est trisomique depuis
trois ans a décidé d'offrir du répit aux
travailleurs du réseau de la santé
un à la fois coviello oblige
ils peuvent venir si c'est leur temps
seulement pour les autres on leur donne
100 % de notre temps c'est gratuit
ils peuvent être un moment présent la
responsable de ce programme préfère
parler de contact et qu'un plutôt que de
thérapie des fois ils viennent mètres du
sommet sera cheval puis prendre une
grande respiration avec le cheval sac
est qu on oublie tout le reste
sur les treize pensionnaires de lober
nl400 dansiez chevaux de calèche ulysse
blanco rostit et maximus semble encore
est née la présence des humains et les
habitués du refuge apprécié leur grand
calme ici à nourrice despatie
radio-canada vaudreuil dorion